what's up everyone we are back talking
about another Tamron Lens that's right
this is the month of Tamron lenses I
mean they've launched I mean as of today
two are going to be available in the
market obviously I think the third one
the fujifilmax mount as well and I want
to touch a course on the 35 150 as you
can tell by the title of this video now
I also did the 28.75 uh G2 lens which is
a fantastic lens I'm actually filming
this review with it right now and that
was a very fast review because there's
really nothing bad to say about that
lens it was fantastic it was sharp great
Auto focusing speeds
um it's compact it's a great Workhorse
lens but this lens falls into that range
but it's also very different it's also a
very special lens and this lens reminds
me of the 2870 F2 uh from Ken and the RF
Mount version and that lens when I tried
it out on a number of views I did in the
past blew me away yes it's a large lens
yes it's an expensive lens but the
Optics that you're getting out of almost
every focal range is like using a prime
and I got a lot of that with the this
lens as well of course this is going to
be for the Sony e-mount so there's a lot
more Sony users out there than they are
about currently right now and I think
for a lot of you who are into wedding
photography event photography
portraiture photography and you need
something that is has a fast aperture to
it at 235 millimeters and of course it
does go up uh you know incrementally but
also having a nice range at 150 but
having that focal range think about this
for a second 35 millimeters to 150. how
much can you cover you got a 35
millimeter prime a 50 millimeter Prime
an 85 millimeter Prime of 100 millimeter
Prime and a 135 and a 150 I mean you've
got yourself covered pretty much to be
the one lens you could carry in your bag
and that's it if you can handle the
weight anyway let's talk about the
all-new Tamron 35 150 F2 to 2.8
di3vxd lens it's in the house
let's talk about it
now like all my reviews have not paid or
sponsored unless I tell you guys but I
do want to thank Tamron Singapore once
again for providing this lens for review
I mean they've been very kind to me and
uh you know I mean the lenses are
fantastic honestly folks I mean these
are Workhorse lenses and as I mentioned
in the 2875 review and because I'm going
to reference that because there is a new
Direction Tamron is taking with their
email lenses when they first came out
with them you know they were relatively
made of plastic and they were you know
they looked inexpensive they were very
non-descript but they had really good
Optical performance and it came at a
very good price point but what we're
seeing from Tamron now and I did see it
in the 2875 and I'm seeing it now in
this 35 one if any different direction
they're taking it's becoming a more
pseudo-premium lens this might be the
only lens you need to pick up anyway
I'll go through all the specs right now
we're going to show you some sample
footage video and photos as well so
let's get down to the more technical
aspects of this lens okay inside lens
with 21 elements and 15 groups we have a
three glass molded the spherical
elements and for a low dispersion
elements inside of this this is a packed
lens okay weight though does come in at
a hefty
1165 grams this is a heavier lens and
this is something that for some people
it may be a turn off or they might be
okay with it but you got to think about
this for a second you're getting a 35 to
150 but at this weight I mean I've tried
Zeiss oaktis lenses at this weight that
were a prime lens I've tried other
lenses at this weight that were a prime
lens I mean
I've tried 7 to 200 this but you got a
35 to 150 you got it so you're gonna
think about that for a second when you
put it all into context about how much
you're getting in this versus the way
because that'll be the big deciding
factor in my personal opinion on this
lens before anything else will be the
weight of it now in terms of your close
focusing Tamron is known for great close
focusing on this so at your widest angle
it's 0.33 meters and at your longest
angle it's 0.85 meters so you're still
getting really good close focusing
distance with this lens just like all
the other tamrans before it and I think
Tamron is really priding themselves on
this and you're seeing other lens
manufacturers trying to get into this
mix as well because they're realizing
how much versatility a Tamron Lens does
give Sony e-mountain users out there
filter size on this lens is 82
millimeters so keep that in mind if you
need to get a filter of course if you're
doing video 82 is pretty much the max
that I always do then I just get a step
down ring if I need to uh use it on
various different lenses but 82 is that
key number and also the length of this
lens is 158 millimeters or 6.2 inches
yes it's a little bit of a longer lens
as you're taking a look right here this
is a
it's not a short lens but I will say
it's shorter than a 70 to 200 out there
on the marketplace but it's also quite
uh it's got some width to this on this
lens of it so as you can see I got quite
large hands and this is how it fits in
my hand like this so it's got some girth
as we say I'm talking about some of the
features of course you do have that USBC
Port so you can uh do a lot of
customization as you can on the 2875 so
you can customize your focus points A to
B you can do firmware updates you can
also adjust the customization buttons
here on the lens as well now you do have
three custom modes on this as in terms
of a switch custom one custom two custom
three autofocus and manual focus switch
and then you also have a lock switch so
you can lock in on your vocal range no
matter where you're at just in case if
you want to stay at 135 or you want to
say 85 or 50 you can lock that in and
you are good to go now this lens is not
a Japanese made lens like the 2875 but
to be honest with you guys I cannot tell
the difference in terms of build quality
I know some people gotta hang up on that
they're always like I want a lens made
in Japan right I want a lens made in
Germany
I want to be real with you guys for a
second I test a lot of lenses and a lot
of cameras and you know
I really can't tell the difference the
manufacturing in China is fantastic at
manufacturing and Thailand's fantastic
in Vietnam Japan also really good and
also these companies have really
stringent policies on the products that
they're having made out in these
countries so I wouldn't worry about it
too much I think that's just more for
Branding than anything else but once you
pick up a lens like this you can be very
happy with the performance you're going
to forget where this lens is made okay
so now that we've gotten some of the
specs inside the lens out of the way
let's talk about this F2 to 2.8 very
interesting variable aperture on this
normally it's 2.8 3.5 4.5 5.6 but at 2
to 2.8 really gives you prime lens
performance in this body so from 35 to
440 millimeters is going to be at f2 now
from 41 to 60 you're gonna be at F 2.2
61 to 80 millimeters at up 2.5 and then
from 81 millimeters to 150 you'll be at
F 2.8 so when you come to think about
that you've got a prime lens in pretty
much every aspect you got a fast
aperture lens great for low light
performance great for blowing out your
backgrounds if you want that beautiful
bokeh which this lens does have you have
a fast Auto focusing Motors in this that
vxt those linear Motors in this so the
auto focusing on your email camera is
going to be lightning quick so you've
got no issues to worry about so right
now what I'm going to do is I want to
show you some sample images that I've
taken with this lens we'll show you some
sample of footage that we recorded with
this lens as well because we actually
did a couple videos on this channel
actually the 2875 2.8 G2 lens that was
recorded with this lens all of it all
which you saw me talking to that was
with this lens so it was very sharp
great bokeh great fall off and we'll
come back and I'll give you my final
thoughts on the 35 to 150.
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so as you saw from the sample footage
and the sample photos this lens is
absolutely beautiful it is I mean this
is going to be a lens that a lot of
people are going to be picking up once
they get their hands on it they try it
out I think this is going to go down the
road of like the 2870 F2 from Canon now
that lens of course does come at a
premium price point this also does can
you know compared to other Tamron lenses
out there but once again you have to
consider what you're getting with this
lens you're essentially getting once
again a 35 millimeter a 50 millimeter an
85 millimeter 100 millimeter 135
millimeter and a 150 millimeter lens
from F2 to 2.8
if you're a wedding photographer event
photographer portraiture photographer
children if you want to capture pets and
I mean this is a versatile lens for
everybody out there you know I really I
don't know who this lens wouldn't be for
obviously Wildlife photography you're
burning because you need a longer focal
range on that of course but for the
day-to-day photographers out there that
just need a really good run and Gun lens
maybe you are using the 2875 maybe you
got a 2470 or maybe you've got a you
know a 24 90 whatever the case may be
and you're like look
should I get into this lens my answer
would be I would definitely try it
I would try it now what do you now
people say what about compared to a 7200
well it's a different lens altogether 70
to 200 is 70 millimeters at 200
millimeters this is a 35 to 150. so
you're almost at that 200 range but
you're going way down to 35 millimeters
so you can even do street photography
with this but it's a little bit heavy
for street photography to mind you I
mean this is I mean I don't think I
would take this out for street
photography some people will if you will
by all means go for it but I would say
this would be a more of a working
person's lens than anything else but
I've absolutely loved using it anyway
I'm done waxing lyrical about the lens
it's fantastic I hope you guys get a
chance to try it when it does come out
in your uh camera stores when it's
available so with that those are my
thoughts on the all new Tamron 35 to 150
di3vxd lens uh let me know your thoughts
in the comment section below is this a
lens you're excited about are there any
uh hesitations on it I would love to
hear from you guys like always follow us
on Facebook subscribe to this channel
like this video helps us out a lot be
safe out there and I'll chat to you soon
take care
foreign